>> Greg: SO HOW DID SNL END UP A
HUMORLESS HELL?
THE "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" ALUM
EXPLAIN HOW THE SHOW GOT SO
DUMB.
ROB SCHNEIDER TALKED ABOUT THE
FAILING STATE OF HIS FORMER
EMPLOYER, "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE."
I BET HE HATES TO CRAP ON HIS
OWN SHOW.
>> I HATE TO CRAP ON MY OLD
SHOW.
WHEN I SAW THAT HILLARY CLINTON
LOST, WHICH IS UNDERSTANDABLE,
THAT SHE WOULD LOSE, NOT EXACTLY
THE MOST LIKABLE PERSON IN THE
ROOM.
WHEN KATE McKINNON WENT OUT
THERE ON "SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE"
ON THE COLD OPENING AND DRESSED
AS HILLARY CLINTON AND STARTS
PLAYING HALLELUJAH, I SAID
PLEASE HAVE A JOKE AT THE END.
DON'T DO THIS.
PLEASE DON'T GO DOWN THERE.
THERE WAS NO JOKE AT THE END.
I WENT "IT'S OVER, IT'S OVER."
IT'S NOT GOING TO COME BACK.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE EVERY SNL
SKIT.
PLEASE, IS THERE A JOKE AT THE
END?
THERE NEVER IS.
HE'S NOT WRONG.
THE COMEDIANS TURNED INTO
POLITICAL HACKS AND THE ACTORS
TURNED INTO JOKES.
NOW THEY'RE ABOUT AS EDGY AS
BRIAN STELTER'S LOVE HANDLES.
THAT'S TWICE NOW.
IT'S STILL HAPPENING IN THE
WORLD OF LATE NIGHT.
>> YOU CAN TAKE THE COMEDIC
INDOCTRINATION PROCESS HAPPENING
WITH EACH OF THE LATE NIGHT
HOSTS AND EXCHANGE THEM WITH
EACH OTHER.
THAT'S HOW YOU KNOW IT'S NOT
INTERESTING ANYMORE.
>> Greg: IT'S TRUE.
EVERY LATE NIGHT HOST STARTED
PLAYING THE SAME CHARACTER.
A SELF-RIGHTEOUS SNOB THAT HATED
ELITES.
THEY'RE AS INTERCHANGEABLE AS
THE MR. POTATO PIECES.
WHY DID WE MAKE THE CHOICE WITH
MISSES AND NOT MISTER?
EXCEPT FOR ONE LATE NIGHT HOST.
WHO COULD THAT BE?
[APPLAUSE]
♪♪
>> Greg: THAT'S BEAUTIFUL.
YOU KNOW, JIM, YOU'VE BEEN IN
STANDUP FOR 60 YEARS?
>> HALF OF THAT.
>> Greg: HALF OF THAT.
YES.
AND YOU'RE WORKING YOUR WAY AT
THE CLUBS, WHICH IS GOOD.
WHAT DO YOU -- WHAT IS THE WORD
I'M LOOKING FOR?
DO YOU HANG OUT WITH WOKE
COMEDIANS AT ALL?
>> YEAH, SOMETIMES.
>> Greg: WHAT IS THAT LIKE?
>> WE TALK ABOUT OTHER STUFF.
TRY TO TALK ABOUT FOOTBALL, SOME
KIND OF SPORTS.
WE DON'T GET INVOLVED WITH THE
POLITICS.
>> Greg: BUT THEY PUT POLITICS
IN EVERYTHING.
>> THEY DO.
WHEN THEY HANG OUT, THEY DON'T
CARE.
THEY'RE INDEPENDENT.
I DON'T CARE ABOUT POLITICS.
MEANWHILE THEY DO.
THEY TRY TO GO UP ON STAGE WITH
THEIR WOKE JOKES AND IT DON'T
WORK.
OH, IT'S ALL TRUMP SUPPORTERS IN
THE AUDIENCE.
OH, YOU JOKE JUST STINKS.
THAT'S WHY.
SPEAKING OF STINK, IT'S
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE."
THEY'VE BEEN ON THE AIR FOR 47
YEARS.
IT'S 1 1/2 HOURS SHOW.
THEY HAVE TEN ICONIC SKETCHES IN
47 YEARS.
LOOK AT THE SCHAPELLE SHOW.
HE HAS MORE ICONIC SKETCHES THAN
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" IN TWO
YEARS.
IT'S OVERRATED.
"SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE" IS LIKE
U2.
THEY HAVE LIKE TEN SONGS.
THEY HAVEN'T PUT A GOOD ALBUM
OUT SINCE 1997.
EVERYTHING ELSE -- THEY GOT TEN
AND THAT'S IT.
>> Greg: I CAN'T ARGUE WITH
THAT.
>> THAT'S WHAT THEY ARE.
THAT'S WHAT "SATURDAY NIGHT
LIVE" IS.
>> Greg: THE FIRST THREE ALBUMS
ARE AMAZING.
AND AFTER THAT EVERYTHING WENT
TO [BLEEP].
>> HOW TO DISMANTLE AN ATOMIC
BOMB.
THE ONE --
>> Greg: THE FREE ALBUM THAT
NOBODY WANTED.
>> NOBODY WANTED.
>> AUTOMATICALLY DOWNLOAD IT.
>> Greg: YOU SHOULD GIVE THIS
AWAY WITH A REAL BOOK.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE?
DO YOU AGREE WITH ROB SCHNEIDER?
A LOT OF PEOPLE -- NOBODY
WATCHES -- A LOT OF PEOPLE
CRITICIZE SNL BUT DON'T WATCH
IT.
>> I FAITHFULLY WATCH IT.
IT'S FUNNY UNTIL THEY TALK
POLITICS.
IT'S FUNNY UNTIL THEY INVITE A
GUEST HOST ON THAT IS NOT A
COMEDIAN.
I HAVE NOTHING TO SAY ABOUT KIM
KARDSHIAN.
BUT WHEN SHE'S ON, WHO IS SHE
PROMOTING?
HER SEX TAPE CAME OUT YEARS AGO
AND SHE'S NOT A COMEDIAN.
>> Greg: IT'S OUT ON DVD NOW.
>> YES, OF COURSE.
IT'S IN YOUR ROLODEX.
>> Greg: YES.
MY ROLODEX.
NEXT TO MY ROTARY PHONE.
>> WHEN THEY BRING IN
POLITICS -- I AGREE WITH
SCHNEIDER.
THAT HALLELUJAH, I WAS WAITING
FOR A JOKE.
THIS IS LIKE DEPRESSING.
>> Greg: IT WAS --
>> IT WAS SO SAD.
>> Greg: THE ONION DOES THIS
NOW.
THEY'LL DO A SERIOUS HEADLINE
BECAUSE LIFE IS SO BAD.
CAN LATE NIGHT BE SAVED?
>> I THINK YOU'RE SAVING IT.
>> Greg: THAT'S ALL YOU HAVE TO
SAY.
[APPLAUSE]
>> Greg: I FORGIVE YOU FOR
COMING DRESSED AS A RESTAURANT
VALET.
>> I THOUGHT IT WAS AN
INFOMERCIAL ON HOW WE COULD ALL
MAKE MONEY.
>> Greg: THAT'S BETTER.
MUCH BETTER.
YOU SELL THE REVERSE MORTGAGE.
>> OR VASECTOMY.
>> Greg: THAT IS A REVERSE
MORTGAGE.
LAST WORD, TYRUS.
>> COMES DOWN TO ONE THING.
WHEN YOU PICK A SIDE, YOU LOSE.
COMEDY IS SUPPOSED TO BE
OBJECTIVE.
SAME THING WITH US.
IF WENT SUPER RED, SORRY.
WE'D END UP IN THE SAME BOAT.
WE MADE FUN OF PRESIDENT TRUMP
WHEN IT WAS WARRANTED.
ONCE YOU PICK A SIDE, THE ART
FORM IS GONE.
>> Greg: WHEN YOU PICK A SIDE,
HAVE A SENSE OF HUMOR ABOUT IT.
>> YOU PICK A SIDE THAT IS NOT
EVEN ON SOCIAL MEDIA ANYMORE.
THE OTHER SIDE IS DOING [BLEEP]
THAT WE COULDN'T EVEN MAKE UP.
SOMEONE SHAKES HANDS WITH THEIR
INVISIBLE FRIEND IN FRONT OF THE
TV, THERE'S SOME JOKES THERE.
>> Greg: YEAH.
>> THE ONLY TIME THEY TRIED TO
MAKE FUN OF HIM, JIM CARREY
PLAYED BIDEN.
HE HAD THE SUNGLASSES ON LIKE HE
WAS A COOL GUY.
THERE'S NOTHING COOL ABOUT JOE
BIDEN.
>> Greg: THEIR IDEA -- WHEN THEY
SAY THEY MAKE FUN OF SOMEBODY --
LOOK, HILLARY, IT'S SO SOFT AND
IT'S ALWAYS LAUGHING WITH THE
CHARACTER.
BUT THEY GO WE DO LAMPOON.
NO, YOU DON'T.
WHO AM